i think this is gonna work looks pretty
cool okay this feels really weird
it's like aggressive
um did i break it oh
burnt oh bad bad bad bad it was going so
well
hi i'm alexis and i'm a chef who's
always up for a challenge
today i'm making a three-course meal
with an appliance that the internet has
chosen for me i'll be tasting everything
myself and i have
no idea what's in this box let's see
what it is
kettle this is great this is great
i use this every single day and it gets
hot
i've actually you know my stove was
broken for a few months and i really
wanted to make eggs and i actually made
it in a kettle and i was at home and i
was like
oh my god i'm chef out of water at home
in real life so i feel
really good about this confidence is
like a 10. i feel great
famous last words i know there's a lot
you can do with the kettle because it's
boiling water
so i'm feeling really good i love giving
myself a theme and i think today's theme
is going to be like
summer picnic for one that's my plan i'm
gonna kind of wing it this time
and see what inspiration hits as i go i
think confidence level
nine let's get started first step the
summer being medley
i haven't even gotten started i feel so
excited about like
this bean situation
heat of water easy i can do that
and then let's just turn it on maybe
i'll start with
snappies i don't totally have a vision
for how this is gonna look shocker
but maybe just on the bias
i think i'm just going to put the
steamer basket in here my impatient side
is like
it's starting to bubble like i can just
do it now i know to properly blanch
vegetables you really need boiling water
so
i just need to be patient so my kettle
when it's done makes a like
sound so i just wait do i take it off i
mean look at that this is boiling
okay yes it it did it made a little
sound okay so i'm just gonna pour it
over
my beans beautiful see how bright and
green that is
that's what you want nice little bean
and taste one
okay so the color's right i'm feeling a
little skeptical
that they're gonna get to the right
consistency
just hanging out in hot water so i'm
gonna just pop them back in
i also uh sorry i forgot the peas just
straight up forgot the peas so
everything's gonna go back in here
while that's boiling i'm gonna prepare
an ice bath so since the kettle shuts
off
once it starts to boil i want to add
these in like
a little before okay there's some bigger
bubbles happening i think this is
safe to add this is not my finest plan
looks pretty cool i like that i can see
what's happening here okay
i think i am gonna stop it so it doesn't
overcook pour it in here
and then look at this magic magic hour
this ice water is just gonna stop them
from cooking and they don't have to send
the ice water too long this is probably
good when it feels like cold
cool that's kind of the sign that you
can pull them out look at that beautiful
beautiful beans i'm gonna grate some
garlic in here not much like a clove
lemon zest olive oil
lemon juice so pretty it's so fresh
summery seasonal yum
so good i also have some ricotta salata
here which is you know
you know ricotta this is like the
saltier cousin i'm just gonna plate that
up
oh i forgot that there was tarragon
i think it adds like such a nice like
floral anisee
flavor maybe some flaky sea salt
[Music]
i think we're done my confidence level
is a 10.
the bean salad went really well so i'm
feeling pretty optimistic
for my chicken salad it's gonna be like
chicken salad and an open face sandwich
very
summer picnic for one appropriate
okay this is weird i'm gonna try to
poach the chicken
in the kettle i have chicken tenders
here rather than chicken breast because
i thought it might
cook faster just your average day
putting chicken in a kettle i think i
should save some as a backup
just in case something goes awry i also
want to infuse
the poaching liquid you know add again
more flavor broken record here some
peppercorns
i thought these little like tea things
would be cute maybe i'll just add like
the whole half of them
some thyme
lemon okay i'm just gonna fill it up
with water
here we go we wait
so while that's going i guess i'll just
start on the salad part it looks like
the chicken's already starting to change
color
i set the kettle at 200. chicken should
reach 160 165
it'll cook for a few minutes after oh
it's totally cooking
look you can see this raw part and
around it looks cooked some chives
maybe some red onions
it smells pretty good it's definitely
not done okay 118
119 120. okay this still has a ways to
go
if i put it on right now it's going to
shut off because it shuts off when it
starts to boil so i think i need to give
it a few minutes
just hang in there a little chicken but
it's totally cooking i also realized i
forgot to add
a bay leaf so i'm going to do that now
moving on to the parsley
on do your thing
some celery leaves gonna have some mayo
i see it shut off okay
how do i do this so i think what needs
to happen
is i need to just like let it cool
maybe i'll temp it again oh oh oh maybe
not
maybe not maybe not 162.
okay you know what i'm gonna do i'm just
gonna press the warm function
and let it like stay warm for a few
minutes like just so i can ensure that
it's fully cooked through
okay okay we're poaching chicken in a
kettle
it is very hot i feel confident i just
feel weird about it you know
okay i guess i'll try uh
slamming wow oh my god
okay confidence 10. this is amazing that
is a good chicken salad we'll do like
just halves i feel like there's a cute
way to do this i'm just gonna do a
not so cute way i feel like you know
usually there's more of a challenge
and i i just it's just weird that that
worked
so well celery leaves this is like
maybe the best chicken salad i've ever
made i feel like this fruit situation
like it can only work
my kind of vision for this this like
pre-made
cake you know i'm not making in the
kettle but like i'm sorry i just i can't
but i think i could toast it
in the base then make a fruit compo and
then put some vanilla ice cream like you
know like kind of a strawberry
short cakey pound cakey summer picnicky
thing sounds really good will it work
who knows strawberry rhubarb classic
combination
okay i'm gonna add some lemon zest
this is weird some lemon juice
maybe a little butter sugar ghee in a
compost
and i think because of the kettle it
needs like a tablespoon or two of water
[Music]
i guess we wait confidence level
apprehensive yeah
i think this is totally gonna work it's
very ferocious
oh it's really steaming wow that is like
really good i think this is like
totally working oh my god
it's like aggressive
oh god okay if i learned anything from
the chicken i think i'm gonna let it
cool for a minute bring it down
and then start it again so it comes back
to a boil i think it needs to cook
longer
so just hang out a little compost
gonna cut some pound cake my idea is to
toast
this in the bottom the good thing is
there's a lot of pound cake so if this
messes up
i can do it again the kettle the kettle
is like the mvp of the appliance world
look at those bubbles it's like fully
boiling i mean i
i think it's done
[Music]
it's done it's delicious i'm so confused
okay okay well
a little liquidy but i think that's okay
i also just want to clarify
that this is not the chicken kettle the
chicken kettle has been retired
what i'm gonna do is put some butter in
the bottom
melt it get it hot have it start to like
bubble
and then add the cake because i'll just
drop a drop of cake in
i don't know we'll see you soon okay it
seems like it's shut off hold on
oh no now it's not turning on
shoot
[Music]
oh
okay this is more like a butter soaked
piece of cake
i i i'm at a loss okay it's just not
working is it broken let me just see if
it's broken
[Music]
oh my god i think it is broken did i
break it
did i break it i'm gonna go to a backup
kettle then i'm gonna come back
and try again i believe this can work
i'm gonna try it without the butter
feels unlikely that that's gonna work
but
the lights on so that's promising okay
it is smoking which seems positive but
it did just shut off
bad oh burnt oh bad bad
bad bad bad bad bad bad oh
[Music]
oh god oh that smells terrible
it is um not really what i was looking
for this this is more like blackened
rather than toasted so i think i'll try
a little bit of butter wait does it turn
on
this is the straw that broke the camel's
back it's a happy camel before but uh
yeah it's not turning on
again and it is just smoking inside
so this is like the saddest thing i've
ever done
maybe if there's ice cream and compote
it's totally fine i don't feel great
about this confidence level
like low
rustic this is a rustic picnic theme
and maybe a little bit of salt on it a
little sweetness a little it's elevated
look at that
cement okay it's summer guys it's summer
who doesn't want to eat this i felt so
confident about the last two
and i feel like this is not my best work
i kind of feel like this is as good as
it's gonna get i think it's cute
i'm gonna taste it that was such a
roller coaster of emotions i feel like
i started on such a high you know and
then i put two kettles out of service so
my confidence right now
is like i don't know it's still high i'm
not an eight first up
bean salad
[Music]
this is lovely with the tarragon with
the ricotta salad it's like an
incredible combination i mean
honestly like 10 10. it's great chicken
salad
i feel like i ate so much of it already
this was the best chicken salad i've
ever had but 10 it's a 10.
probably like a 20 50. it's so good
now this fruit situation
i mean wow the combo is the real star
here and it's like
the kettle for the compo i would
legitimately do that again
in life like that is it's it happened so
fast the toasting of the pound cake i'm
gonna say
not the best move it's totally fine
because only a third of it got toasted
toasted burnt but it's fine we don't
like we don't even need to talk about
that part this is it's delicious it's
delicious
all in all a truly awesome meal that i
would make for myself i'd make it for my
friends like
it is so good and i don't think anyone
would ever know
that this was done in a kettle which is
really the whole point right
let me know in the comments what you
would make in a kettle
i'm dying to see i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
you